To parse the date column, we're going to be using D3's built-in time
formatting accessed through d3.time.format and similar to
the time format extreme we used in our dimple.js code for d3's formatting.
We give it a similar string, which uses strftime variables.
In this case, the things here, which are preceded by a percent.
%d-%m-%Y and so forth, which each correspond to a day,
month, year or time format.
And then d3 simply pattern matches the pattern we told it to expect our
dates in.
And the actual date string.
Here I've put an example of the format of dates in our data file where we have
the day as a two digit integer, a dash, the month as a two digit integer.
A dash, the year as a four digit integer and then the hour and
minute of the day contained within these parentheses.
So going to our format string, percent d corresponds to a two digit day.
The dash corresponds to a dash.
And since we don't want it to actually.
Pull out the dash into the date object that gets returned.
It simply skips over that.
%M corresponds to the two digit month.
A dash simply says skip the dash.
%Y matches a four digit year and then we have a space
left parenthesis two digit hour between zero and 23,
a colon, and then a two digit minute, and then rest, a space, H,
and right parenthesis, are simply the trail of the string.
And to use this formatting, we simply, on the format object,
call the parse function and pass in the string we'd like to convert.
In this case, D bracket date corresponds to some string
that'll look similar to this that I've shown here as an example date.
Gets patterned matched to extract the appropriate day, month, year and time.
And then we restore that in the date column.
So in this case we're over writing the data column which is
a string initially here, with a date java script object.
One little nuance that I feel I should mention is that the time of the game is
actually the local time of the country where the game's held.
Or for simplicity.
And since, for a single year or a single World Cup
we only care about the relative times of each game, we can simplify things and
not worry about converting all of the local time zones across all of the years.